hi everyone welcome back to plays of the
week brought to you by ochodo TV
the content shown in this video has been
submitted by various players to ochodo
TV Clips are compiled weekly for a
series of videos highlighting specific
players of their gameplay for the Tekken
Community by no means was it reused or
stolen without permission to the
rightful owner
thanks
[Music]
thank you
perfect
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
another
one
[Music]
thank you
one two three
things
[Music]
thank you
thanks for watching be sure to leave a
like And subscribe also huge shout out
to our patreon supporters if you want to
further support this Channel and making
more content like these please visit the
link to our patreon page below the
description
in ochodo TV send in your Clips by
following these steps before you submit
your Clips make sure the quality of the
video is clear put your IGN as a file
name for your video
limit submissions to three to five Clips
a week per category
don't spam submissions and don't send
folders with your Clips on it avoid
full-length matches or just cut the clip
you want on the desired play Until the
End of the round
next send your Clips via Dropbox in the
correct category
always find it on the description of
every ochodo TV series
once you upload your video file if it
prompts you to give your name just put
in your igf
also these are things you can do if
you're sending a recorded replay match
[Music]
please understand that it may take some
time for some clips to be featured
because of the review process
[Music]
all right
thank you